So for this quiz, I want you to play around with the code and the web server and
see if you can figure out how it's working. And then, to modify the server code.
So, when the search query is something that's not found in the corpus, like
wisdom. Instead of seeing none as the response, we want to see a search like try
searchwithpeter.info. And as a reminder, when you modify the code, you might
need to restart the server. So you should remember to kill the current server
using Ctrl-C and then restart the server when you change the code to make sure
it's running the code that you actually have. I know I haven't explained
everything in this code yet and there are some things you haven't seen before
here. But I think, if you play around with a little bit on your own, you should
be able to figure this out enough to be able to do this.